the front and the back door lock were
unable to uh get into the residence
she stole the line
that's quick we're trying to
get one of them to come out every time
she tries to go to the door he's pushing
her on the bed
and it's only her and him in the house
any animals
543 we go to bridge then
[Applause]
543 radio we have the mother on the line
correct we don't have any general
contact with the sun
the call taker attempted to speak to him
as well but he's not cooperating but yes
we have direct contact with the mom
david trudeau radio can you just tell
the mama that we're going to be reaching
the door if one of them doesn't come
down the door please
see if that'll work
so far
she was advised of that and she said
that was ocean king
you have a kid yep
[Applause]
that's correct
oh
yes
no
[Applause]
let's wait until we get another door
okay please
county police
county police make yourself known
make yourself known
where yet
is he armed
let me see your hands get on the ground
now
get on the ground right now
hands behind your back
don't move
you're gonna get tased
get on the ground right now
get on the ground
boy
14 13.
uh
you want to cooperate i don't leave a
little
uh
ugh
oh
get on the radio
fuck ugh
[Music]
upstairs
county police
make yourself go
is he armed
let's see your hands still on the ground
now
deal on the ground right now
trans body back
don't move
get on the ground right now
get on the ground come on come on
do that boy
more units
three on channel
you're gonna cooperate
fucking
oh
motherfuckers
county police
make yourself known
where yet
is he armed
look at your hands get on the ground now
get on the ground right now
transplant the back here
they're gonna get tased
back
what do you need
[Music]
okay
gonna get tased
[Music]
just stay in there for me
what do y'all need
stay
i don't have to put
i can't
what does he need oh shoot him again
what do you need oh hey put your gun
down just put your gun down just put it
down just put it down oh hey put it down
put it down
hey you're good just put it down oh hey
take a deep breath
hey oh hey get on the radio ask for fire
stop fire i know i just like it i got it
out i just got it out
hey hey hey stop stop
start fire
here come get up and come to me
help no okay
come on go help him out come here come
to me
oh come to me come to me come to me get
him out help him get him out
help him
hey help him up
come on okay what are we doing we're
fine
okay we're here
[Music]
please
okay
[Music]
are you breathing
are you ready
[Music]
yeah but he's still breathing still
breathing man okay i'm keeping pressure
on it okay
start
oh
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
okay
he's shy he's getting the finger
should we bring him down
[Applause]
johnny can you
here you get one arm i'll get the other
lift like this
i got you richie just stand up for us
the best you can best you get
here yeah you get i'll get the top you
get the legs
[Applause]
[Music]
best
you